when i feel that there's levels of
double standards or hypocrisy
and somebody wants to try to have me
follow them and impose them on me
then yes i'm going to question that
are you willing to be in a long-term
relationship with someone like that i do
want to see you know is this person
willing to grow with me or are they
stifling my growth
um
because you know i i like as i said i'm
a free spirit which means that i'm not
going to conform to normal social rules
do you feel like you're going to lose
you who you are with me
sometimes i do
eve
i've done a nice amount of interviews
this season with the couples
and it is kind of surprising that you're
here by yourself without muhammad
why is that what can you tell me you
know we're kind of
getting through this
time frame and making sure that things
work so
um
[Music]
sometimes you know you have to kind of
move forward with you know the things
that you need to do and so
i'm here today it's by myself and so
um we'll just see you know what the
future holds
yeah have you been watching the season
back
i have yes i have how do you feel
i think you know there's things that
are said that i'm like whoa did you
really think that
or things that oh i didn't know that you
felt that way so it's a little
challenging like for example
one of the things was that you know eve
knew
what to expect if i did hide anything
from you let me know
because i was very clear with you about
everything which i
actually didn't um that was kind of a
blanket statement what do you say to
people who are thinking how can you be
in a committed relationship and not have
these serious conversations about your
cultural differences when he told me two
weeks into us
communicating and getting to know each
other that
i was not going to be judged for my
culture or religion i took that to heart
and you know if he
did want me to
if he was serious
that he wanted me to potentially
follow the muslim faith then he should
have said that to me
and knowing that i would not convert you
know that what it may that meant
probably could have ended our
relationship right then and there if
that was conveyed to me and that was
never conveyed to me we were in a global
pandemic we were hyper focused on
encouraging
us to stay
um going and positive and he would get
sometimes sad and depressed because he
didn't know when he was going to see me
so i would try to you know help uplift
him and things like that and then i was
struggling because theron was out of
school for 15 months so we were kind of
hyper focused on being there like
psychologically and emotionally for each
other um you know that those maybe those
conversations that um we were kind of
focused on the love maybe not
necessarily the real interworkings of
precise religious topics right it seems
like there were i guess a lot of
assumptions made and not necessarily the
communication of what do you expect from
me in this relationship and here's what
i expect from you because i think that's
where the confusion kind of comes in
you're dating a muslim man or marrying a
muslim man and most people would say
y'all don't talk about okay what does
our future look like how does this
how are we gonna navigate these two
spiritual ways of being i was very clear
with him about how i am like i'm a
professional woman like i do you know of
course well you know take on these roles
as a wife but i'm definitely not a
housewife so i was very clear about like
you know i you know women
like sometimes don't work there but i
that's not my situation so
we did talk a lot about the future about
what he would do when he got here as far
as like personal training and he's a
food engineer and the job opportunities
here
so we were kind of focused on those
things versus the real religious
aspect and he
i felt like he knew that i wouldn't
convert so those those parameters
wouldn't be placed on me but then upon
arrival because i think the thing that's
hard with i think egypt is that the
religion
dictates the
laws
i think that there was that he didn't
realize like what a huge difference
it would really be
so i have a fan question here
dion wants to know why would you bring
over a muslim man but then not respect
his religion as his wife so what do you
say to fans who feel as if you don't
respect his religion
i
think i have made it clear that i
am open to what he wants to follow but i
am not islamic i'm not i'm not a muslim
woman i don't follow that faith and i'm
not converted
and um i don't he knows that that
that that was not going to happen so why
is it on me that i have to
change for him i mean he chose to be you
know pick somebody outside of his faith
outside of his religion
so
you know if you wanted somebody to act
muslim then you should
you should have picked a muslim woman to
you know if you wanted to abide by islam
looking back now what do you why do you
think he picked you
do you think it was genuine interest
because
like you said if that's what he wanted
why didn't he go after that
right we were actually in the same place
like i had written off marriage he had a
bad experience of being previously
engaged and basically didn't want to get
married either and actually told his
mother that and she was upset because
that's not following
kind of their culture he likes to work
out he was following like fit body
hashtag and there popped up me
okay and then he
thought when he saw that picture and
went to my profile he was just like
thought i was like the most beautiful
woman he's ever seen
yeah and so when we began talking
we didn't realize that you know for him
i think he thought like oh cool this is
somebody i might be able to like
practice my english with because i like
english and i
and so but then when we began talking we
just
totally clicked
um i mean i literally had on my phone at
that time this picture of this like
egyptian thing and i had dreams about
egypt since i was like in third grade
and so i was supposed to go to egypt
actually i ended up going in september
like
um three months after we met and i was
actually
like thinking about going on trip in
october with a friend of mine and i
ended up going earlier because i met him
and then i just left and so the
synchronicities were like clicking right
and that flight like the the price
the the time frame like one night it was
looking and like if the stars aligned
you know
like i'm coming and he was like what
and it was our like first meeting was
like two people that just hadn't seen
each other in a long time that was like
and it was such an amazing connection
and and
considering i went along
all the way across the world
didn't know the language never been
there before you know like taking this
huge risk and chance and then it just
being felt so natural like our
connection felt so natural
yeah i'm a pretty spiritual person too
so who knows like maybe you all did know
each other before i i believe so like we
definitely feel like we've had past
lives together we feel like we have a
twin flame connection which he doesn't
usually use that terminology but i think
so and i think that we are the epitome
of that cultural difference age
difference distance and you know this
union is it's a very like amazing like
kind of bond but also it's difficult
because it's challenging your souls to
basically like grow
so sometimes you mirror each other or
sometimes you push each other's buttons
and i'm like all right
you know so i've always wanted that in
my life i've always wanted somebody who
actually makes me grow continue to grow
because i i love
like continuing to evolve this girl it's
easier said than done because the growth
is painful
the growth can be painful oh yeah no
it's not fun sometimes
yeah if i'm to be honest as a viewer
i haven't really seen the spark you know
or what it is that made you fall in love
what is it about muhammad that made you
fall for him
i for my first time in my life
felt that somebody had my back he
literally like saw straight through me
like into my soul
and um
literally from the tone of my voice
the my expression on my face and video
chat like he knew exactly what was going
on with me and that was such an amazing
beautiful thing because
um for him to just be able to tune in to
me like it to me was such a deep
emotional connection and he just
conveyed to me even though he wasn't
physically here
that he had my back and that was
something that i was really searching
for so you felt like he understood you
emotionally or he was able to read you
emotionally in a way you've never
experienced before yes most definitely
we'll just see through
the just see deeply like he'd say to me
like on video chat like i look into your
eyes and i see this like innocence of
like a child like that you're he saw
like my soul
oh
well speaking of that do you think that
when he came
that changed because if anything it
seemed as if
he wasn't seeing you or maybe he was
seeing you but wasn't fully appreciating
you for who you were for who you are
yes agreed um i feel like there was a
little bit of a shift which was
difficult for me because i was like
where was that man who always had my
back kind of thing then it was
surprising to me because we interacted
every single day
like multiple times a day and then all
of a sudden like you're not approving of
my life when you were pretty much
viewing it from afar knowing exactly
what i was doing where i was going
day in day out so that that was really
difficult what do you say to viewers who
feel as if muhammad is manipulative
because
there there are a lot of people who
think
he is
um
i would say kind of like those blanket
statements sometimes aren't necessarily
based in fact so you know that's can be
a little frustrating to me
um
in the sake of you know saying something
that's not necessarily
you know it's a generalization i would
prefer somebody should just be
straightforward whether you're mad angry
sad whatever it is to just not try to
say something that you don't mean maybe
passive aggressively um but just be very
straightforward
yeah yeah i have another fan question
jennifer wants to know how do you feel
about muhammad picking and choosing what
to follow and what not to follow about
his religion i have a problem with that
because
when i feel that there's levels of
double standards or hypocrisy
and somebody wants to try to have me
follow them and impose them on me
then yes i'm going to question that when
something seems like it's a double
standard or has an aspect of like
hypocrisy in it no that doesn't sit well
with me and i don't think it's fair
because you know just like the bikini
thing like you know if you don't
you're upset about that but you can post
pictures of yourself and apparently
there is like rules for muslim men that
they had their pants have to be looser
so their pants are supposed to be above
the ankle
so so that's a red flag for you though
because that does it's a reflection of
his character in a sense i mean i don't
know him as a human being but
you know that's it's sketchy yes it does
kind of set up a red flag is that
really you know if you're using your
religion to kind of execute something or
is that just controlling
so that does bother me and i believe in
equality and i think maybe that's
something different here in the sense of
like if he came here and thought oh he's
just gonna you know kind of impose like
this male dominant energy or religion
i'm a very kind of confident independent
woman so that's probably not going to
work that well so you either kind of
like accept that and begin to
acculturate and things like that or yes
maybe it's not going to work like if
you're just stuck in those ways and want
to be stubborn and not want to grow and
understand me as a person and a woman
and who i am
are you willing to be in a long-term
relationship with someone like that i do
want to see you know is this person
willing to grow with me or are they
stifling my growth
um because you know i i like as i said
i'm a free spirit which means that i'm
not going to conform to normal social
rules i mean
obviously like even our situation is not
normal and nor have i kind of lived my
life you know as a normal
like even you know people look at me and
think like no you're not a normal 48
year old and he didn't think i was this
he thought i was like much younger he
didn't realize i was older either just
when we initially met my perfect woman
in my imagination is
that women will love me as my mother
so
someone
prepare everything for you to make your
life easier tell me this how did you
feel when muhammad said i want my
partner to act like my mom
and what he actually meant was i want to
be loved unconditionally as a parent he
wanted you to cook him breakfast honey
before you went to work i was dreaming
that day i will be having breakfast in
bed he wanted to be babied and taken
care of that's the gist that we as
viewers got
right and i think that that was
definitely like a misconception and and
definitely taken it the wrong way
because of just the language barrier and
him not knowing how to convey that
properly and so
definitely he does you know he can make
his own food and he when his mom would
go to his grandmother's he was in charge
of making his own food so yes of course
i wish i could have like spent that
morning with him but i couldn't
[Music]